اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من الرياض وهذه ابرز عناوين
اليوم
ازيل طاقه السعوديه يقول بان التوقعات
كانت سببا لمعظم تقلبات الاسعار خلال
العام 2022
الخارجيه الايرانيه تعلن عن تعيين
الدبلوماسي علي رضا عنايه السفير لها في
السعوديه
وفي السعوديه قصه شاب النجا من موت محقق
بقلب متبرع له بعد توقف مفاجئ لقلبه
الصناعي
الرابعه ايضا
[موسيقى]
الحج السعودي تنفذ اليوم ثاني فرضياتها في
المشاعر بمشاركه اكثر من عشره الاف مشارك
حياكم الله ضمن فعاليات منتدى قطر
الاقتصادي الذي انطلقت اعماله في الدوحه
اليوم حذر وزير الطاقه السعودي الامير عبد
العزيز بن سلمان مجددا المضاربين في اسواق
النفط من تلقي ضربات موجعه كتلك التي
تلقوها في ابريل الماضي عندما اقرت دول في
اوبك بلس تخفيضات طوعيه وانتقد الامير عبد
العزيز مجددا وكاله الطاقه الدوليه قائلا
انها اثبتت ان الاستمرار بالخطا يحتاج
لموهبه خاصه على حد تعبيره وفي الجلسه
ذاتها توقع وزير الدوله لشؤون الطاقه
القطري سعد الكعبي ان تواجه اوروبا ازمه
اصعب في الشتاء المقبل
من الشتاء الماضي وذلك اذا بدا الاقتصاد
في الانتعاش
معنى من الخبر المستشار في شؤون الطاقه
ومدير الدراسات دراسات الطاقه في منظمه
اوبك بلس الدكتور فيصل الفائق دكتور فيصل
حياك الله معي في نشاط الرابعه من الرياض
وكاله الطاقه الدوليه لديها موهبه موهبه
الخطا باستمرار هذا ما قاله وزير الطاقه
السعودي الامير عبد العزيز بن سلمان ما
الذي يقصده اولا هناك رسائل واضحه جدا
ومهمه ايضا من سمو وزير الطاقه السعودي
الامير عبد العزيز بن سلمان في هذا الوقت
المهم الذي يتاثر فيه تتاثر فيه اسواق
النفط من ضبابيه عاليه او حاله عدم يقين
رسائل واضحه جدا بان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه جاهزه ومستعده لجميع
السيناريوهات وهذا هو ديدنها دائما ان
تكون على هبه السداد في جميع الحالات
وجميع السنوريهات التي ممكن ان تحدث في
اسواق النفط وراينا دور المملكه في اثناء
الجائحه وفي كثير من الاحداث في اسواق
النفط العالميه وكيف هي مؤثره وهي داع
توازن اسواق نفط واستقرار الاقتصاد
العالمي على عكس الجهه الاخرى من ما ذكرته
طاقه الدوليه بالنسبه لوكال الطاقه
الدوليه للاستاذ نايف يعني واضح جدا يعني
لا نستطيع ابدا ان نلوي عنق التداعيات
التداعيات السلبيه
والنتائج الكارثيه لدراسات وتوقعات الطاقه
الدوليه التي حاولت ان تستثمر في ذروه
الجائحه وان تدعو المستثمرين للعزوف على
استثمارات الطاقه استثمارات المنبع في
النفط والغاز والوقود الاحفوري لماذا لكي
تتجه الى الى منحنى صفري غير مدروس وغير
منطقي وغير واقعي بغض النظر عن تلبيه
الاحتياج العالمي من امدادات الطاقه
والطلبه المتزايد عليه واضح جدا ان ما
نعيشه اليوم او تقلبات اسعار النفط اللي
كانت في العام الماضي هي نتائج واضح
لاخطاء دراسات وتوقعات الطاقه الدوليه
الطاقه يدعو بذلك الى الحذر من اخذ هذا
النهج في في في التاثر وتاثير السمن
المنبع من دراسات وتوقعات وطاقه الدوليه
التي رايناها دائما واطعن اتوقع انه هذا
اول تصريح للطاقه السعودي تعليقا على ما
ذكرته طاقه الدوليه لاننا يعني ممكن ممكن
سمعنا يعني تحذيرات من من امين عام منظمه
اوبك ولكن
واضح جدا انه الان الاخطاء التي تعيشها
اسواق النفط جراء تلك التوقعات الخاطئه
جراء ما كان من توقعات خاطئه وغير مدروسه
وغير محسوبه اثناء الجائحه وايضا لا ننسى
يعني اوقات الطاقه الدوليه غلطه الطرف
اثناء الجائحه عن التيسير الكمي
واغراق السوق به اثناء الجائحه في الجهه
المقابله رايناها ايضا غضت الطرف على
التشديد السياسات النقديه من البنوك
المركزيه ورفع سعر الفائده وما الى ذلك من
تاثير التضخم الصدر العالم فيما يخص
المضاربين ايضا
قال المضاربون كما هو الحال في اي سوق
موجودين حتى يبقوا ابلغهم باستمرار بانهم
سيتالمون ذكر بانهم تالموا في ابريل
ويعني قال قال لهم بما معناه احذروا اريد
السؤال هنا ما الذي يرى او يحذر منه
الامير عبد العزيز بن سلمان فيما يخص
المضاربين في اسواق نريد يعني تفصيل لهذه
النقطه طبعا وزير الطاقه يحذر المضاربين
يعني اول شيء ينصحهم
بالالتزام بادبيات السوق الادبيات السوق
هذا السوق سوق واحد نحن نعيش في عالم واحد
واقتصاد واحد ويحذر ايضا منه انه انه
تداعيات الاعمال المضاربين قد يكون لها
نتائج كارثيه رايناها في ابريل 20 20
عندما انهار خام غرب تكساس الى الى السالب
وهو يحذر اسمه وزير الطاقه من من ربما
اعاده هذا السيناريو اذا لم يلتزم
[موسيقى]
السؤال هنا يعني من ماذا تتحوط بلس في
المستقبل القريب برايك دكتور فيصل هناك
هناك عده سيناريوهات ممكن ان تحدث عندنا
عندنا مع الاسف الشديد نقص كبير في
استثمارات المنبع كان دعت اليه وكانت
الطاقه الدوليه في ذروه الجائحه كانت
مستثمره وكطاقه دوليه في في نقص الطلبه
الشديد جراء الدائحه الجائحه ودعت الى الى
وقف استثمارات في الوقود الحفوري في النفط
والغاز والان نرى نتائجه هناك نقص كبير في
استثماره المنبع وهذا ما سيؤثر سلبا اكيد
على امتدده الطاقه في السنوات القائمه
نحتاج الى ضخ استثماري جدا قوي لكي يعود
تعود امدادات الطاقه لتلبي الطلب المتزايد
ما بعد الجائحه لن يكون كما قبل الجائحه
وهذه النصائح ليس فقط ولكن ايضا
للمستثمرين النفط سواء تتكلم عن الوقود
على على النفط التقليدي او النفط الغير
التقليدي النفط الصخري والذي راينا انه
هناك في ايضا تاثير التضخم الاقتصادي على
انشطه النفط الصخري الامريكي اشكرك جزيل
الشكر من الخبره المستشار في شؤون الطاقه
ومدير دراسات الطاقه في منظمه اوبك سابقا
الدكتور فيصل الفائق شكرا لك دكتور فيصل
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الايرانيه عن تعيين
الدبلوماسيه علي رضا عنايه سفيره لطهران
في السعوديه اذكروا ان علي رضا عنايه عمل
في جده في عده مناصب بالخارجيه كان اخر او
عمل في عده مناصب الخارجيه كان اخرها عمله
كمساعد لوزير الخارجيه الايراني وهو الذي
شارك في جميع جولات الحوار مع السعوديه في
بغداد ومسقط وبكين
ومعنا من طهران مدير المركز العربي
للدراسات الايرانيه الدكتور محمد صالح صدق
صدق دكتور محمد مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض اريد ان اسال بدايه عن
دلاله تعيين هذه الشخصيه شخصيه دبلوماسيه
ليست عسكريه سبق وان عمل في الخليج في
السعوديه كنائبا للسفير في مدينه جده ايضا
عمل في القنصليه هناك وعمل ايضا سفيرا في
الكويت دلاله اختيار علي رضا عنايتي
مساء الخير لك وللمشاهدين انا اعتقد تعيين
علي رضا بعنايتي في منصب السفير لدى
المملكه العربيه السعوديه له دلالات كبيره
اولا عنايتي عملت في جده وعملت في الكويت
وعملت في عدد من الدول العربيه وتحديدا
الخليجيه
وبالتالي هو في اخر منصب له هو رئيس
المدير الدائره الخليجيه في وزاره
الخارجيه الايرانيه وايضا شارك في
اجتماعات ذكين في اجتماعات
مدراء الامن القومي في كلا البلدين في
ادار الماضي وايضا في اجتماع وزراء
الخارجيه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
وجمهوريه ايران الاسلاميه بالاضافه الى
انه شارك ايضا في اجتماعات بغداد وبالتالي
يعني اعتقد ان اختيار عنايتي الذي يتقن
اللغه العربيه ايضا وهو اختيار مدروس
ويريد ان يحقق الرغبه الايرانيه في
العلاقات الثنائيه مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ويبدو لي بان هناك قرار ربما
يكون ابعد من وزاره الخارجيه وهي قرار
القياده الايرانيه بتحسين العلاقه مع
الدول مجلس التعاون الخليجي وتحديدا مع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لما لهذه الدوله
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
مكانه في العالمين العربي والاسلامي ومكان
ايضا في المجتمع الدولي بالتزامن مع تعيين
علي رضا عنايه كسفير في السعوديه
المجلس الاعلى للامن القومي في ايران شهيد
تغيرا في راس الهرم علي شمخ ان يتحدثون
هذا التزامن هل له دلالات له معاني فيما
يخص اتجاه العلاقات وتطبيع العلاقات
الايرانيه مع السعوديه
ان يعتقد كما قلت بان قضيه العلاقات
الايرانيه السعوديه هي ابعد من وزاره
الخارجيه وابعد المجلس الامن القومي ويبدو
لي بانما حسب ما افهم ذلك بانه هناك
رغبه وقرار من القياده الايرانيه والحكومه
الايرانيه بتعميق وتعزيز العلاقات مع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وفتح صفحه من
التعاون والتنسيق بين البلدين وبالتالي
تغيير امين مجلس الامن القومي الايراني
علي شمخاني واستبدالي لعلي اكبر احمديان
انا لا اعتقد بانه يخدم او لا يعتقد بانه
يعني
يرتبط بالعلاقات الايرانيه السعوديه
بل انه ربما نستطيع القول بان الملف
العلاقات الايرانيه السعوديه هي احد
الملفات المهمه على طاوله علي اكبر احمد
يانو وهو يدخل مجلس الامن القومي وبالتالي
اعتقد بان احدى المهام الرئيسيه لامين
مجلس الامن القومي الايراني الجديد العميد
احمد يان اعتقد بان احد المهام الرئيسيه
وفي الاولويات هي العلاقه بين ايران
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه وبين ايران
ودول مجلس التعاون الخليجي بشكل عام
الدكتور محمد يعني قعدته وكررت كم مره على
ان هناك اتجاه في ايران ليس من وزاره
الخارجيه يعني اعلى من ذلك باعاده
العلاقات مع السعوديه وتطويرها وياتي
السؤال هنا هل هناك اجماع في
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه على اعاده
العلاقات مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بشكل كامل بالاضافه الى تطوير هذه
العلاقات وليس عادتها فقط
دكتور محمد
طيب يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال بالدكتور
محمد صالح صدقي صدقيان
سنحاول العوده الي مره اخرى
دعا وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه ان الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع الى الالتزام
بالهدنه المتفق عليها وقال بلينكن ان
العنف الذي ارتكبه طرفه الصراع ماساوي
ومدمر وبلا معنى مشيرا الى ان العالم يصر
على حل تفاعلي
ان العنف الذي ارتكبته القوات المسلحه
السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع الشهر
الماضي كان ماساويا وبلا معنى ومدمرا لقد
اتحد العالم كله في الدعوه لانهاء هذا
الصراع والاصرار على حل تفوضي ان الاتفاق
بين القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم
السريع على هذه الاتفاقيه لوقف اطلاق
النار لمده قصيره كان نتيجه الدبلوماسيه
المكثفه وشراكه الوثيقه بين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والولايات المتحده
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني بلينكن من
انتهاك وقف اطلاق النار في السودان وهدد
بلينكن بمحاسبه المنتهكين وفرض عقوبات
عليهم محملا الجيش والدعم السريع مسؤوليه
تطبيق اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار في البلاد
اذا انتهك وقف اطلاق النار سنعرف وسنحاسب
المخالفين من خلال عقوبات نفرضها ووسائل
اخرى متاحه لنا لقد ظللنا الصعوبات
للتواصل الى وقف اطلاق النار هذا لكن
مسؤوليه تنفيذه تقع على عاتق القوات
المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع ان
الحل الدائم للصراع يتطلب اكثر من ذلك
بكثير اريد ان اوضح ان المدنيين في
السودان يجب ان يكونوا من يحددون مسار
السودان للمضي قدما
هذا اعلنت وزاره الصحه بان قوات الدعم
السريع تتمركز في 28 مستشفى وست مؤسسات
صحيه على انه صحه السودانيه ياتي بعد
ساعات من دخول الهدنه الجديده السودان حيز
التنفيذ والتي شهدت مناطق متفرقه في
الخرطوم خلالها شهدت خروقات واطلاق نار
وتحدثت وسائل الاعلام عن سماع اصوات
مواجهات وغارات جويه جنوب العاصمه وفي
الضواحي الشماليه الشرقيه بالاضافه الى
وقوع اشتباكات في شارع الغابه وسط الخرطوم
افدى شهود عيان بتحليق مقاتلات في سماء
المدينه واستمرار المواجهه في بعض المناطق
لا سيما مع سماع ذوي قصف في الشرق لم
يختلف الحاء الكثيره لدى سكان ام درمان
وبحريه
[موسيقى]
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه التصدي
لمجموعه قوميين اوكرانيين توغلوا في
مقاطعه بلكرود الحدوديه كما جاء في البيان
اقل المتحدث باسم الوزاره ايغور
كوناشينكو فان القوات الجويه والمدفعيه
شاركت في جهود التصدي للمجموعه المسلحه
وقتلت 70 منهم مشيرا الى فرار بقاياها الى
داخل اوكرانيا
رابعه مستمره تتابعون فيها بعد قليل
قناه العربيه تحصد 38 جائزه بينها خمس
جوائز عن الفئه الذهبيه من جوائز تيلي
العالميه
حياكم الله من جديد دشنت وزاره الحج
والعمره التجربه الفرضيه الثانيه لنقل
وتفويج الحجاج بالمشاعر المتمثله في تفويج
اكثر من ثلاثه الاف حافله لتشمل 6 مراحل
من عمليات التفويج واكثر من عشره الاف
مشارك من جانبها اوضح وزير الحج والعمره
الدكتور توفيق الربيعه ان الوزاره تسعى من
خلال هذه التجارب الى اختبار القدره
التشغيليه والتخطيطيه للشركات واختبار
فعاليه الانظمه التقنيه الداعمه لاعمال
تفويج والنقل وتكاملها مع البنى التحتيه
طبعا نحن سوينا الفرضيه الاولى كان بعدد
تقريبا 2000 حافله الان زودنا عدد
الحافلات عدد الحافلات اكثر من 3000 حافله
وعدد المرشدين اكتمل 4000 مرشد يصاحب هذه
الحافلات عده اهداف نحن مستهدفين حقيقه
هذه من هذه التجربه واهمها اللي هو رفع
السقف الجاهزيه عن كل القطاعات بما فيها
وزاره الحج العمره والشركات التي تعمل بما
فيها البنيه التحتيه المخصصه لنقل الحجاج
[موسيقى]
في حديثه امام الجمعيه الصحيه السنويه
لمنظمه الصحه العالميه بعد اسابيع من
انهاء حاله الطوارئ الصحيه العالميه حتى
مدير عام منظمه الصحه العالميه تدرس
حتى الدول على تنفيذ الاصلاحات اللازمه
للاستعداد للوباء المقبل وتعزيز تمويل
وكاله الصحه التابعه للامم المتحده
لا يمكن ان نترك كل هذا على الطريق ونمضي
اذا لم نجري التغييرات اللازمه فمن سيفعل
ذلك واذا لم نقم بها الان فمتى عندما يطرق
الوباء التالي الباب يجب ان نكون مستعدين
للاجابه بشكل حاسب وجماعي ومنصف من اجل
تعزيز التعاون الدولي اتفاق الوباء التزام
باننا لن نعود الى الحلقه القديمه من
الذعر والاهمال التي عرضت عالمنا للخطر
سنمضي قدما بالتزام مشترك لمواجهه
التهديدات المشتركه من خلال الاستجابه
الجماعيه
وزاره الصحه السعوديه دكتور عبد الله
عسيري دكتور عبد الله معي في نشاط الرابعه
من الرياض استمعت لهذا الحديث ويمكن يعني
الكثير من الناس تداولوا هذا هذا التصريح
لمنظمه الصحه العالميه بان هناك وباء قادم
كان هناك تحذيرات ايضا حتى من شخصيات
سياسيه على سبيل المثال الرئيس الامريكي
في وقت سابق بانه يجب علينا الاستعداد
الوباء القادم هذه التحذيرات يا دكتور كيف
ممكن نتعامل معه على محمل الجد وبان هناك
وباء قادم فعلا
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته اولا
نبارك قناه العربيه على هذا الكم الهائل
من الجوائز المميزه
والحقيقه الكلام اللي ذكر في اجتماعات
جميع العام المدني الصحه العالميه يعني
ذكر مرارا وتكراما قبل هذا المحفل وهو
حقيقه يواجهها البشر من بدء الخليقه ان
الانسان محاط باعداد كبيره جدا من
الكائنات اغلبها فيروسات قد تتسبب في
امراض معديه ومن وقت الى اخر تتسبب في
اوبئه ولكن نادرا ما تتحول هذه الاوبئه
الى الى جوائح ومثل الجوائح اللي شهدناها
في كوفيد اشياء تحصل مره او مرتين لكل مئه
عام لكن الملاحظه انه خلال العقود القليله
السابقه كان هناك تزايد في اعداد
الفيروسات والامراض التي قد تتحول الى
جوائح لاسباب كثيره ولكن هذا يضع العالم
امام مسؤوليا انه يكون مستعد يحصل لا احد
يعرف اذا كان متى يحصل ذلك ولا احد يعرف
جدته ولا يعني توقيت ولا مكانه يعني يا
دكتور اليوم لو سمعنا مثلا مدير منظمه
الصحه العالميه او شخصيات سياسيه نافذه
وربما عندها معلومات يعني ليست متاحه مثلا
للجميع التعرف عليها
والحديث بان هناك وباء قادم استعد الوباء
القريبا يعني هل ناخذها على على محمل الجد
والصدق ام لا نعتمد على الابحاث على
الدراسات على ما تقوله منظمات او وزارات
الصحه في البلدان المعنيه بهذه الاوبئه ان
انتشرت فيها اوبيا
يعني الموضوع يحتاج الى توازن يعني
الهدف ليس الذعر وليس وضع الناس في قلق
دائم الهدف وان المنظومات الصحيه
والحكوميه انها تكون على اهبه الاستعداد
انها تكون لديها انظمه رصد فعاله لديها
قدرات بشريه قادره على التعامل مع هذه
الامراض يعني تجربه كوفيد اظهرت انه يعني
لدينا قصور كبير جدا على مستوى العالم في
موضوع رصد الامراض المعديه لدينا قصور في
التعامل معها لدينا قصور في الموارد
البشريه الذين قصور في التمويل في اشياء
كثيره جدا يعني يستلزم ان تكون موجوده
للتعامل مع مثل هذه الاوبئه وتقليل
الخسائر البشريه والاثار الاقتصاديه
النجمه عنها علميا يا دكتور هل الجوائح
تعقبها اوبئه او جوائح اخرى في مده زمنيه
متقاربه
الاوبئه مستمره هي طبعا نقصد بالاوبئه هو
مجموعه من الاصابات بمرض معدي واحد في
مكان محدد ولكن يعني هذه الاوبئه في يعني
فترات متباعده تصل الى خمسين او ستين سنه
قد تتحول الى يعني مرض جديد يتسبب بجائحه
لكن لا يمكن التنبؤ بوقته ولا يمكن التنبؤ
بشده ولا نوع الفيروس او الجرثومه التي قد
تسبب مثل هذه الجوائح اشكرك من العاصمه
السويسريه وزاره الصحه السعوديه الدكتور
عبد الله عسيري شكرا يا دكتور
ابراهيم القاسم شاب سعودي تم تشخيصه حالته
بانه يعاني من مرض فشل القلب وتمت زراعه
قلب صناعي له من قبل مستشفى الملك فيصل
التخصصي الذي يعد رائدا في اجراء هذا
النوع من العمليات الاولى في المملكه
والشرق الاوسط التفاصيل مع غاده الفهد
هي اجهزه راح تكون شغاله 24 ساعه لو طفت
ووفيت كل اختصار
[موسيقى]
بهذه الكلمات يستذكر الشاب السعودي
ابراهيم القاسم البالغ من العمر 34 عاما
معاناته السابقه مع مرض فشل القلب الذي تم
تشخيصه عام 2018 بعد الام مفاجاه شعر بها
واعاقت نشاطه قرر على اثرها اطباء مستشفى
الملك فيصل التخصصي في الرياض زراعه قلب
له من متبرع بعد البحث اتضح لي انه العلاج
راح يكون ان شاء الله في مستشفى الملك
فيصل التخصصي
فرفعنا لهم طلب وجت الموافقه
واذكر انه دخلوني اللي هو في العنايه
بعدين طلعوني فتره كذا بسيطه بحيث انه
يعني يشوفون وش الدراسات تطلع معاهم
اتضح انه راح يكون في عمليه زراعه زراعه
قلبي عندي صار شبه فاشل او يعني
منتهي الا الا شيء بسيط
437 عمليه زراعه قلوب اجرتها وحده زراعه
القلب في مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي منها
67 عمليه لاطفال دون الرابعه عشره من
العمر عاده في الناس اللي بيكونوا في سن
صغيره او في في مقتبل العمر حياه ما منلجا
الى الملخص الصناعيه الا كجسر للزراعه لكن
في الناس اللي لا تنطبق عليهم
الزراعه او في سن متقدمه نلجا الى المضخات
الصناعيه ويرجع لها كحل يعني دائم مثل
حاله المريض ابراهيم زرعنا له مضخ في
الايمن والايسر وهذه اليسرى كانت تسحب من
البطين الايسر الدم وتضخه في الاورطه اللي
هو الشريان الكبير اللي يوزع الدم على
بقيه الجسم والبطينه الايمن زرع فيه كمان
مضخه اخرى مثل اللي في يدي دائمه تقوم
باخذ الدم اللي موجود في البطينه الايمن
اللي غير مؤكسد وارساله الى الشريان
الرئوي علشان يتاكسد ثلاثه اعوام عاشها
ابراهيم على المضخات الصناعيه التي توقفت
فجاه عن العمل في اكتوبر الماضي فاضطر
الاطباء لاتخاذ اجراء سريع وفي خطوه ساعات
معدوده تم استبدال قلبه بقلب متبرع متوفى
دماغيا وبدعم عائلته وفريق الاطباء اصبح
يعيش حياه طبيعيه
الحين الحمد لله ما في ولا سلك بس في
علاجات العلاجات هذه هي اللي تخليك يعني
بعد الله هي اللي تخلي الجسم طبيعي كامل
بدون علاجات
يعني فيها معوقات كثيره
تكلفه مليونيه لعمليه زراعه القلب الواحده
الا انها تنفذ بشكل مجاني في المركز
الوحيد بالسعوديه والخليج الذي احيا الامل
في قلوب عشرات المرضى منذ اربعه اعوام
غاد الفهد العربيه الرياض
ومعي هنا في استديو الرابعه ابراهيم
القاسم حياك الله ابراهيم الحمد لله على
السلامه
وايش اللي مريت فيه اللي مريت فيه انه
انتكست حالتي في 2018 بالقلب الطبيعي
تدهورت الحاله بشكل يعني مره ما يؤس منها
راجعت كذا مستشفى
استقرت الامور الحمد لله الى مستشفى الملك
فيصل التخصصي
وانا في لحظاتها قالوا لي انه مالك الا
عمليه زراعه لكن المشكله في توفر القلب
فاللي حصل انه
تم تركيب مضخات للقلب اللي هي القلب
الصناعي الى حين اللي هو زراعه القلب هي
مضخات كانت تعمل مع مع قلبك الطبيعي صحيح
مش يعني تقوم بعمل القلب هي مساعده للقلب
مساعده للقلب بحيث انه يشتغل يكمل يكمل
دوره الدمويه طيب وبعدها هالمساله انت
توقف قلبك لفتره طويله يعني وانت كنت حاسس
اصلا فيها
بالمضخات توقف يمكن تقريبا اسبوع او شبه
توقف اللي هو اقل من العشرين وانت ما تدري
انا ما ادري لكن احس بالام في الصدر
رجعت للالام القديمه اللي هي قبل تركيب
المضخات
رحت الطوارئ بعد ما شافني الاستشاري تبعي
قال لي انه يعني وضع قلبك بدا يتدهور نفس
الاول فلازم نسوي لك صعق كهربائي
وبعدها تجلس عندنا فتره الى حين توفر
القلب يعني الوضع اتدهور بالصناعي وقتها
لا اروح واطلع وجهي لكن احس بالام بس
[موسيقى]
تقريبا اسبوعين ونص تقريبا ممارسه حياتك
بشكل طبيعي بديت اطلع بس انه يعني في علاج
طبيعي وفي اشياء هذي اللي هي يعني بحيث
انه علاجات زي ما قلت قبل العلاجات هذه
الى الان يعني هذه خلاص مستمره اكيد اكيد
هي اللي هي هي اللي تسبب الاشياء اللي
تخلي الاعضاء انها ما تحارب الجسم الداخل
عليها دائما يقولون انه الشخص اللي يعيش
بقلب غير قلب الطبيعي تتغير مشاعره تتغير
الاشياء اللي يحبها الاشياء اللي ما
يفضلها الحاله هذه مرت معك غيرت فريقك مثل
الشجعه والاكل اللي تحبها نفس كل شيء واحب
باستا ورجعت تاكل باست
قبلوا بعد
[ضحك]
طيب يعني ما تغير ابدا عليك اي شيء بعد ما
زرعت القلب الثاني في المشاعر في التعامل
في الغضب في الفرح في في هذه الامور اتوقع
انها عاطفيه اكثر يعني مشاعر هذه ممكن
تجود في اللحظه اللي هو انت تحس بتعب تحس
انك شوي مختلف بس انها تعدي لكن هل هي
جايه مع القلب لا هذه مشاعر اتوقع
دائما يصير الحديث عليها فانا سالتك يعني
لانه اكثر من شخص يعني او اكثر من قصه
سمعناها انه شخص استبدل استبدل القلب
الاساسي لا بقلب شخص اخر او متبرع اخر
فتتغير ربما مع احيانا الرغبات او المشاعر
او غيرها لا لا الاجهزه اللي كانت موجوده
ايضا في مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي كانت
تسبب لك عائق في حياتك الطبيعيه العاديه
اي نعم تسبب لي لكنها هي تخليني امارس
الحياه الطبيعيه بحدود بحدود بحدود بحدود
مره ضيقه لكنه ترجع تعيش طبيعي كيف
تكلفتها الجهاز الواحد فوق 600 الف الله
يعز حكومتنا الله يعزهم يعني شيء كان في
جسمي فوق المليون وكان مؤقت مؤقت مؤقت
يعني تخيل انه يعطيك مليون يقول لك ترى
تقعد ثلاث سنوات فيه بعد اربع سنوات بعدها
احتمال نغير او احتمال
الحمد لله على سلامتك الحمد لله شكرا
جزيلا لحضورك معي هنا
ابراهيم القاسم المتعافي من مرض فشل القلب
شكرا جزيلا لك
في مقابله على شاشه العربيه كشفت طبيب
الكويتيه يعقوب العصيمي عن لحظه انقاذه
طفله اردنيه بعد تعرضها للاغتناق
كان في زجاجه ماي ما كان عليه خطا اذا
تنتبه كانت على الطاوله
فاحنا دارسين وعارفين انه غالبا واغلب
حالات الاختناق تكون بسبب قطع ازجاج في
الماي وانتبهت على الطفله كانت حاطه يدها
حوالين رقبتها اذا منتبه هذا دلاله واضحه
انك كان في اختناق
وبلش يطلع عليه وجهه يكون احمر فالحمد لله
اللي الله سخرني والحمد لله اللي الله
قادني وفضل علي ومن علي اني اكون موجود في
هذه اللحظه اني انقذ روح بشريه رب لك
الحمد والله يا ابن الحلال اللي تمر عليك
حاله واحده في حياتك فهذا انجاز لانه
الله سبحانه وتعالى يقول في كتابه ومن
احياها فكانما احيا الناس جميعا
فتخيل انك تحيي حاله من الاله فهمت فانا
الصراحه ادعي يعني ان تكون ماده مضافه
للثانويه او المتوسطه او تكون حتى من بين
رخص فتح المحلات التجاريه انه يجب على
الموظفين يكونون عندهم دورات والموضوع
بسيط وسهل جدا سهل جدا يعني ممكن بساعتين
ثلاثه وهو بس الممارسين الصحيين يقدرون في
هذا الدور
حصدت قناه العربيه 38 جائزه من بينها خمس
جوائز من الفئه الذهبيه من جوائز التينيا
التي تعنى بتكريم التميز في مجال
التلفزيون والفيديو تاتي الجائزه التي
تنظم سنويا في امريكا في نسختها الرابعه
والاربعين وشاركت فيها القنوات والمؤسسات
الاعلاميه مثل نتفليكس وبي بي بي سي فوكس
ومن ابرز الفئات التي فازت بها العربيه
البرامج الثقافيه والتاريخيه والتصميم
الابداعي والوثائقيه بالاضافه الى
السوشيال ميديا واستخدام تقنيه الواقع
المعزز
الرابعه مستمره وفي بعد قليل
مجموعه ام بي سي تطلق اذاعه جديده في
السعوديه للناطقين باللغه الانجليزيه
حياكم الله من جديد رحب مجلس الوزراء
السعودي بتوقيع طرفي النزاع بالسودان على
اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار قصير الامد كما
اعرب مجلس الوزراء السعودي عن امله في ان
تركز المحادثات السودانيه على وقف دائم
للاعمال العدائيه وتفعيل العمليات
السياسيه
تنطلق اول اذاعه باللغه الانجليزيه
بالكامل ام بي سي من السعوديه بثلاثه
ترددات في الرياض وجده والدمام تنطلق
ببرامج شبابيه منوعه ومذيعين عالميين
سوق الاعلام في السعوديه والاذاعه تحديدا
بدا يتزايد بشكل ملحوظ خلال الفتره
الاخيره ام بي سي لاود محطه اذاعيه جديده
تبث في مدن الرياض والدمام وجده بترددات
مختلفه لتكون اداه جذب للمستمعين من غير
الناطقين بالعربيه
انساني
في السعوديه ما زالت لدينا الفرص وهذه اول
اذاعه غربيه وشريحه الشباب المتحمس
والمفعم بالحياه في السعوديه والذي يرغب
في الاستكشاف كبيره كما ان عدد الوافدين
والمقيمين في المملكه بدا يزداد بشكل كبير
وهذه الاذاعه للاشخاص الذين يفضلون
الاغاني العالميه والاشخاص الذين يبحثون
عن علامات مثيره ونابضه بالحياه اربعه
برامج منوعه تذاع على ام بي سي لاود كل
برنامج منها يحمل شخصيه تعبر عن محتواها
من برامج الصباح وحتى قائمه افضل الاغاني
العالميه مع المذيع الامريكي
انا اربع برامج اول شيء برنامج الصباح
اسمه ديدي ويك اب هو يوميا الاحد للخميس
من الساعه سته للساعه 10:00 صباحا بقدمون
جي ار ودانا عنا بعد الظهر كمان من الاحد
للخميس من الساعه 4:00 للساعه سبعه المساء
طبعا المذيعه الامريكاني المشهور بيرجع
عنا يوم الخميس ويوم الجمعه ابتداء من
الساعه عشره المساء عنا برنامج اسمه هو
عباره عن ساعات متتاليه من دي جي اس
انترناشونال ولوكل فعلنا اسامي مثل
مارتن جاريكس شوتك واسامي غيرها طبعا
للساعه 4:00 للساعه 7:00 بعد الظهر كمان
عنا امريكا
اكيد ام بي سي لورد اف ام حيكون محتواها
الاغاني الكارنت هيتس وعندنا البريك تايم
شو اكيد برامج ترفيهيه ثقافيه يعني
اجتماعيه العروض الحيه في حفل اطلاق اذاعه
ام بي سي لاود عكست الروح الشبابيه التي
يقدمها مذيع البرامج وتمثل روح البرامج
القادمه التي ستبث في سبتمبر المقبل من
الرياض شاهد المتروك العربيه
الاجواء خلال هذه الايام متغيره بشكل
متسارع بسبب تغير حركه الرياح التفاصيل في
تقويم معهد الزعل
[موسيقى]
الصيف فلكي وواقعي الفلكي ثلاثه شهور من
22 يونيو الى 22 سبتمبر والواقعي اربعه
شهور من منتصف مايو الى منتصف سبتمبر
والعامه يقسمونها الى بدايه وشده ونهايه
فبدايته مع موسم كنه ثريا عذب السجايا
وعوده باول السنه متى تزينه سوالف واخذ
علومه وشدته في موسمي ذبحت وجمره القيظ
وهو موسم هبوب رياح السموم هبت رياح الصيف
وتغير الجو وانا ويلي في ميداني سمومه
ونهايته في موسم مرخيات الجلاائد قضى
الصيف عن جرد السبايا ولا بقى من القيظ
الا مرخيات القلايد ونحن الان في موسم
الكنه وهو موسم شده لسع الشمس مع الجلسات
الليليه الرائعه من يحب الشمس يبكيها
الغروب ومن يحب الليل يضحك للقمر ومن يحب
انسان ما يقدر يتوب لا صار هذا الحب
يسواله عمر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والاجواء خلال هذه الايام متغيره بشكل
متسارع فلها وجوه عده فهي تنتقل من وجه
الى وجه اخر تغيرات سريعه حركه الرياح
وتغيرات بطيئه درجات الحراره احذر تخاوي
منه بالوجه رجال خاوه اللي لا طحت تفداك
عينه السيف وهو السيف انواع واشكال سيف
شطير وسيف بالبيت
زينه
[موسيقى]
شهيده مدينه جده اغلاق احد اكبر الاسواق
الشعبيه في جنوب غرب مدينه جده المعروف
بسوق الصواريخ بعد سلسله من حوادث الحرائق
خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين وكشفت مصادر
للعربيه ان قرار الاغلاق جاء بعد اجتماع
بعدد من الجهات المعنيه في محافظه جده تم
من خلال مناقشه وضع هذا السوق لا سيما في
ظل تسجيل العديد من المخالفات وسط توقعات
بان يخضع الموقع للتطوير بشكل كامل خلال
الفتره المقبله
من جده يلتحق بين مراسل العربيه عبد
المحسن الحربي عبد المحسن مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في نشاط الرابعه من الرياض
يعني في تساؤلات كثيره بصراحه عبد المحسن
على ما يحدث من حرائق بشكل ربما مستمر
ومتسلسل في سوق الصواريخ بجده ما الذي
لديك من
تملكه من معلومات حول هذه الحرائق
نعم نائب بالفعل كل هذه التساؤلات اثارت
تساؤلات اخرى وايضا بحث عن اجابات لما
يحدث هنا في سوق الصواريخ هذا السوق
الكبير الممتد ولعل الارقام الكبيره جدا
هنا تشير وتعكس ربما الحاله الاهمال الذي
عاشها السوق خلال عشرات السنوات الماضيه
يتحدث عن هذا السوق الذي بدا من عام افتتح
في عام
1980 في في مطلع الثمانينات وبعد ذلك تطور
حتى اصبح الى وضعه الحالي يحتوي على عشرات
الالاف من المحلات بالاضافه الى نتحدث عن
عشرين الى ثلاثين الف من القوى العامله
يعملون في هذا السوق السوق تعرض لحريقين
خلال عشره ايام
وهذه الحريقين يعني كان هنالك اسباب كثيره
ولكن ربما نتحدث عن بعض الاسباب التي تم
الحديث عنها وهي ضعف مقومات السلامه وكما
تشاهد في الصوره ربما هذه هي المره الاولى
التي يتم مشاهده فيها سوق الصواريخ وهو
اكبر سوق شعبي ليس فقط في جده ولكن على
مستوى السعوديه والشرق الاوسط نتحدث عن
ارقام كبيره من ناحيه حتى المبيعات تحدث
هنا في هذا السوق تخطط 400 مليار دولار
مليون دولار عفوا بحسب تقديرات اقتصاديه
بالاضافه الى وصلت المبيعات على مستوى
سنوي مليار ونصف المليار ريال سعودي هذا
الاغلاق الذي ربما لم تشهده ويشهده
العاملون هنا في هذا السوق وحتى مرتدي منذ
افتتاح ربما باستثناء جائحه كورونا التي
تم الاغلاق فيها بشكل كامل حتى الان لا
يعرف الى اي مدى سيستمر هذا الاغلاق تحدثت
مع بعض العاملين هنا بالسوق قالوا بان
عمليه عمليه اغلاق السوق تمت بالطريقتين
الاولى اغلاق السوق بصبات خرسانيه
بالاضافه الى
اطفاء التيار الكهرب بشكل كامل على كافه
السوق الذي يحتوي على خمسه اسواق رئيسيه
بداخل هذا السوق لذلك نشاهد الارقام
الكبيره جدا التي نتحدث عنها من ناحيه
القوى العامله 30 الف بالاضافه الى ما
يقرب على 12 الى خمسه عشر الف محل في هذا
الموقع في سوق الصواريخ هنالك العديد من
المخالفات التي تم الحديث عنها من قبل
خبراء وايضا مطلعين هنا في جده على هذا
السوق بشكل كامل اتحدث عن التستر التجاري
منتشر في بشكل كبير جدا التهرب الضريبي
ايضا منتشر بشكل كبير جدا ايضا هنالك تحدث
عن مقومات السلامه
والمخالفات التي تتعلق بعرض الملابس بعرض
القطع التي يتم بيعها بشكل
معايير السلامه فبالتالي تم اغلاقه من قبل
الامانه وبانتظار نتائج هذا الاغلاق والى
متى سيستمر
جدا مراسل العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي على
كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل
مع هنا نصل الى ختام الرابعه
هذه ابرز عنا
وزير الطاقه السعوديه يقولوا بان توقعات
كانت سببا لمعظم تقلبات الاسعار خلال
العام 2022
الخارجيه الايرانيه تعلن عن تعيين
الدبلوماسي علي رضا عنايه سفيرا لها في
السعوديه
وفي السعوديه قصه شاب النجاه من موت محقق
في قلب متبرع له بعد توقف مفاجئ لقلبه
الصناعي
الحج السعودي تنفذ اليوم ثاني فرضياتها في
المشاعر بمشاركه اكثر من عشره الاف مشارك
قناه العربيه تحصد 38 جائزه بينها خمس
جوائز عن الفئه الذهبيه من جوائز تيلي
العالميه
شكرا لكم لكرمي لطف المتابعه الرابعه
انتهت الى اللقاء
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات